unless you've been living under a rock
for the last decade you're probably well
acquainted with teen heartthrob High
School Musical Alum and Baywatch babe
Zac Efron we're literally the same age
but for some reason I still think of him
as like a teenager so yeah he's not
really my vibe but there's no denying
that the kid is talented and attractive
as and most recently the triple threat
grapes the cover of Men's Health
Magazine where he spilled the tea on
everything he eats in a day and his
extreme movie prep diet key word being
extreme wonderful 10 1 being not so
extreme in 10 being extremely extreme I
give this a 9.5 hey one I'm Abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be taking a look
at everything that Zac Efron eats in a
day please take a minute here to pause
the screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning as we will be discussing
pretty restrictive diets so please feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and if you
are not already subscribed hit that
subscribe button and follow me on Tick
Tock and Instagram at Abby's kitchen let
me hop in here really quick to tell you
about my sponsor for today love and pies
so at the end of a very busy day I just
love to zone out on my phone and love
and pies has become my new favorite game
it is a free to download online game for
tablet or mobile that lets you build
your dream Cafe I kind of a secret
fantasy of me retiring and owning like a
little Bake Shop in a Country Town
Summer remote so this kind of helps me
live out that dream without any kind of
real life commitment love and pies
follows a single mom character Amelia
green who works to restore her cat Cafe
while uncovering a bunch of dark family
secrets and Mysteries the game is very
much multifaceted so you've got
character development competitions and
you get to use your creativity to
customize and decorate your dream Bakery
it's a feel-good game that feels like
the perfect little Escape my favorite
part of course is the decorating I mean
there's just something so comforting and
nostalgic about dreaming up a place to
buy cinnamon buns and pies so if you
want a little escape from your hectic
life check out the link in my
description and download 11 pies today
alright lovelies let's get into it I
guess the philosophy around my current
diet is intermittent fasting mixed with
getting enough nutrition to sort of
sustain me throughout the day okay so
interim fasting doesn't necessarily need
to result in weight loss since it
doesn't explicitly restrict the calories
you can eat in a day but as I discussed
in my video on intermittent fasting
right here the main reason why it often
does result in weight loss is simply
because we suck at making up for lost
calories when we skip one or more meals
that said it's often not recommended for
folks who need to ensure they're getting
a lot of nutrition in the day to support
very active Lifestyles because it
naturally limits our eating
opportunities but of course Different
Strokes for different folks and if it
works for Zach and he feels that he
isn't deprived or depleted at the end of
the day then ultimately it works for me
I started intermittent fasting just
after I stopped being vegan my body
wasn't processing the the vegetables in
the right way so first of all this
language might be pretty confusing for a
lot of people watching being vegan
doesn't cause you to not process foods
the right way likely what he means is
that the plant-based diet was maybe hard
on his digestion but as I discussed in
my video right here this is likely
because plant-based diets are typically
one very high in fiber and two pretty
high in fodmaps now while fiber is
obviously important for regularity and
other health benefits adding too much
fiber too quickly can cause a lot of
potential bloating constipation and gas
now while these symptoms usually subside
as your body adapts it is recommended
that folks who aren't used to eating so
much fiber do so gradually while also
drinking enough water to support
regularity eating more plant-based Foods
also translates to eating more
fermentable carbs called fodmaps which
can be difficult to tolerate for some
folks This is highly individualized so
it is most likely the case that a few
veggies in excess amounts just like
didn't Vibe with Zach's digestion not
all veggies across the board regardless
I'm all about finding a pattern of
eating that works for you and if
following a vegan no longer served Zach
then I think this 100 makes sense and
please guys be kind in the comments and
be sensitive to everyone's unique
Journey for most roles you change
something but I think probably the one
role that I had to change the most for
was probably Baywatch that movie I
adopted a really really specific eating
regimen clean fish or meat with sweet
potatoes like that I just did that the
entire film I mean I don't want to yuck
someone's yum here but the thought of
living off strictly meat fish and sweet
potatoes every day sounds like straight
up torture also what exactly is clean
meat like cooked without fat unseasoned
bathed in soapy bath water before eating
like I guess we'll never know but what
we do know is that attributing the word
clean to food is just another example of
diet culture moralizing food as we're
eating the same thing every day I have a
whole video discussing the implications
of this but in short when we eat the
same thing every day we limit our food
variety to just a handful of foods which
can negatively impact our nutrition
status microbiome diversity and
digestion it also goes without saying
that eating the same thing every day
gets boring real [__] fast making it
difficult to derive any pleasure and
satisfaction from our meal and we
actually have some research to suggest
that we absorb less nutrition from Foods
we don't enjoy but I also think that
this diet monotony tends to be a bit of
a tactic in dieting circles because it's
very hard to overeat foods that you find
really boring basically this diet looks
a lot like a typical bodybuilders prep
high protein low fat low carbonate fiber
and low FODMAP it technically gives
preference to fuel for building muscle
so mainly protein and hopefully enough
carbs while still maintaining a calorie
deficit sweet potatoes are also lower in
fodmaps in moderate amounts so because
this diet also doesn't include other
fruits and veg it's likely a low bloat
diet ideal I guess if you need your abs
to be visible at every angle in every
shot so that was that was the most
extreme I'd ever gone I think it was in
ketosis that that entire film I would
definitely have to agree that eating the
same meals three times a day is
certainly extreme and also highly
unnecessary often we see folks on these
bodybuilding type preps find a few foods
that work and they feel too nervous to
change it up out of fear that it will
somehow throw everything off but if
ketosis was his goal he would likely
need to limit himself to no more than
two medium sweet potatoes a day and then
just fill the rest of his calorie needs
with a ton of meat and Zach is actually
the first to admit that surviving off of
potatoes and meat to maintain his
physique is unrealistic and miserable as
he shared with Men's Health that
obtaining his Baywatch body was not
something he would ever do again or
recommend to anyone else Not only was he
over training and eating the same three
meals a day but he also had to take
powerful diuretics to achieve his
chiseled Baywatch look and this is
actually a common practice by Pro
bodybuilders and fitness competitors
because the diuretics help to flush out
anymore water attention to make the
muscles look more defined however use a
diuretics to achieve a dry physique is
highly controversial as not only can It
increase the risk of dehydration
electrolyte imbalance and muscle
cramping but in worse cases it can even
be fatal in fact Pro bodybuilders
Mohammed benziza and Andreas munzer both
died of Health complications from the
use of diuretics another Pro bodybuilder
Paul dillette collapsed on stage from
extreme dehydration and electrolyte
imbalance as a result of abusing
diuretics and even though he survived he
recently shared that his heart actually
stopped beating and he was officially
pronounced medically dead so yeah use a
diuretics is not to be taken lightly
whatsoever on top of that Zack also said
that the process of achieving his
Baywatch look caused him to develop
intense insomnia and long-term
depression so while I applaud Zach for
being very candid about his is difficult
experience and calling out the harmful
consequences of this process it doesn't
look like it's held him back from doing
it again as he was recently forced to
bulk up for his new film The ironclaw so
I think it just goes to show that much
like women men in Hollywood are not
immune to the pressures to meet a body
ideal at any cost toughest diet I've
ever done for a role probably just not
eating I've done that for a couple times
oh my gosh like just when we thought
things couldn't get worse folks
this is not a diet this is straight up
starvation and an extremely harmful
message to put out to an audience of men
who likely aspire to obtain Zack's
physique it's especially harmful when
this behavior is glorified by titling
the cover story in the media Zac Efron
the hustle the muscle folks restricting
food options to only three foods is not
a hustle abusing diuretics is not a
hustle and starving yourself is most
certainly not a hustle
there's absolutely nothing admirable
about this this is dangerous and
potentially life-threatening Behavior
like why is the media glamorizing this
this reminds me of that super cringy
clip of Megan Fox when the women on The
View were like petting her and praising
her for never eating anything fun
um but yeah I don't I don't have cheat
days I don't I don't eat anything fun
like we know this messes up a lot of
women but it also messes up a lot of men
too and Zach is a perfect example of
that let's not forget that following his
days on Baywatch he was quickly called
out for his alleged dad bod despite
still maintaining a muscular slim
physique like what the actual and this
yoyo cycle is seemingly never ending for
a typecasted celebrity like Zach Zach
himself has even said it's not the time
of the place to put pressure on yourself
unless you really need to be shirtless
that entire film
which tends to be the case for me
sometimes and this ultimately puts that
much more pressure on Zach to go to
extreme lengths to live up to this image
and maintain his brand so much so that
it allegedly impacts his physical and
emotional well-being and while the
majority of research in Eating Disorders
looks at women and their pursuit of
thinness we also know that the pursuit
of muscular ideal in men can increase
the risk of muscularity-oriented
disordered eating AKA mode and muscle
dysmorphia and I am by no means
diagnosing Zach with an eating disorder
I mean I also get that a lot of actors
just see this as part of their job but I
just want to flag that a lot of these
behaviors and practices that he engages
in during his movie prep diet aligned
with diagnostic criteria for these
disorders and that these behaviors are
encouraged recommended and glamorized by
the industry so to Zach these may just
be temporary behaviors for the sake of a
movie role it's like part of the job
that he may or may not be able able to
distance himself from after filming but
to someone else watching these behaviors
may serve as disordered eating
inspiration and that's a problem with
that said let's take a look at what Zach
actually eats in a day allegedly when
he's not preparing for a movie role so
typically I'll break fast around 10 30
or 11 but that's after I do some cardio
so regardless if you are intermittent
fasting or not some folks might prefer
to do a fasted workout because they
either don't have the time to prepare
eat and digest breakfast in the morning
or maybe they just don't like the
feeling of having a lot of food in their
stomach during a heavy workout but
proponents of intermittent fasting often
suggest that a fasted workout helps to
burn body fat because being in a fast
estate uses up fat stores for energy and
yes it is true that while facet cardio
may help to burn fat it doesn't
necessarily equate to weight loss
research actually shows that there is no
difference in weight loss between fasted
and non-fasted exercisers even though we
see an increase in fat oxidation during
fasted exercise it doesn't actually burn
any more calories than had you done that
exercise later on in the day after a few
meals nor do we see an increase in
calorie burn over the course of the day
weight loss ultimately comes down to a
calorie deficit not fat burning so
exercise during a time of the day that
feels convenient and supportive for you
first meal of the day usually starts
with bone broth I really love bone broth
it's satisfying and it's good for your
stomach so bone broth is one of the few
celeb endorsed Wellness foods that might
actually live up to some of the hype for
one it is nutrient rich and loaded with
collagen protein and micronutrients like
calcium iron magnesium and potassium and
two we also have some in vitro animal
research suggesting that it may help to
improve our gut health but it's worth
noting that bone broth is pretty low in
calories so two cups provides less than
100 calories so while it may be
satisfying and provide a healthy dose of
protein we would definitely want to
follow this up with some actual
substantial fuel some sort of veggies
with a really clean source of protein
whether it's chicken beef venison elk
okay so I hate the clean verbiage but I
do love that we are prioritizing some
veg here and at least we're getting more
diversity here with the protein options
versus just Meat and Fish on the
Baywatch diet still waiting on some
carbs and fat in this day because so far
it's just basically straight up protein
then yes I usually have my highest
carbohydrate meal sort of in the evening
that's usually another really good
source of meat and healthy carbohydrate
like sweet potatoes or quinoa so I am
curious to know why Zach would
prioritize his carbs in the evening and
not earlier on in the day or like closer
to his workout
um even if Zach is intentionally going
low carb which by the sounds of it I
would assume that he is it would
actually be metabolically more
beneficial for him to get his carb fix
earlier on in the day as that is when
our bodies are more insulin sensitive in
other words when we're more insulin
sensitive our body is more efficient at
absorbing glucose from carbs and using
it for energy as for the meal itself I
am glad that Zach has an option other
than just sweet potatoes even though
quinoa is admittedly also boring
sorry not sorry
yeah on cheat days I love to eat massive
amounts of Pancakes if I'm doing Pancake
Day it's it's a lot of Pancakes I'll go
through a whole box of cardiac cakes if
I'm gonna have a cheat meal I still want
it to be at least semi-good for you I
think we need to redefine good for you
because if this means eating a whole box
of Pancakes just because it has protein
in it then it also means eating over 2
000 calories and 175 percent of our
daily sodium recommendation in one
sitting in just basic protein pancakes
and eating a whole box of pancake mix
because it's got protein in it it's also
kind of redundant for muscle building
because even though the total provides
over 145 grams of protein only around 13
to 20 percent of this can actually be
utilized for muscle protein synthesis
this also means that the two meals a day
that Zach had while intermittent fasting
Also may limit muscle protein synthesis
which is why intermittent fasting is
generally not recommended for building
muscle song I also think if Zach has to
eat a whole box of pancake mix on his
cheat day that this is a clear
indication that he is one not eating
enough during the week and two depriving
himself so vigorously of the foods that
he actually enjoys like I don't see why
these protein pancakes couldn't be
incorporated into his prep every day
honestly folks something is not right
here and it's pretty apparent that dye
culture has left its mark on zag we have
all The Usual Suspects like cheat meals
moralizing language extreme restriction
over exercise and even more concerning
behaviors like overt starvation and
abusing diuretics all at the expense of
his mental and physical health and it's
clear that he knows this himself and
even though he says it and even though
we can all acknowledge that yes he's
doing this for a role I still know that
people will see his body and believe
that it's worth the risk than trying it
themselves but I cannot emphasize enough
how dangerous these regimens are and
they most certainly should not be a
representation of men's health and it
just goes to show that regardless of sex
or gender health is still largely
defined by how we look and our body size
regardless of the obnoxiously risky
behaviors that it takes to get there
there's really no winning in the world
of die culture no matter who you are wow
winning and I just hope for Zach's sake
that he doesn't have to learn this
lesson twice but on that note that's all
that I have for you guys today if you
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
who or what you'd like to see me review
next subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]